I'm so tired
I put on I put on We're dead That's still not even here When
we're kidding Let's put a little Rough dad A really rough
dad I had a really, really rough day!
What the fuck did I stream yesterday?
Why is my sound so hot?
All right, wait a minute, Doki.
I thought we're working today.
What the fuck is this?
I don't know.
I'm just thinking maybe this will help.
Help me stay focused right now.
Also, I found the cheat sheet.
If I keep looping, I'll never be late.
I'm figuring it out.
I got you now.
I can just...
I game the system.
I'm metagaming right now.
I'm metagaming.
Can't patch this out.
I had a really...
It had a really fucking rough day.
Give me a second.
I need to save this for the choicer.
Choicer.
It has an intro style on it.
It's fucking bullshit.
I demand the devs to patch that out.
That's bullshit.
I should knock down.
out never thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank
you a pretty good day day so when you're a disciple of
mickey mouse may some of my good day rub off on you through
the power of capitalism thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you uh let me see okay um i'm gonna turn this down
a lot of the music is the music really loud all right so i
found this working like you know how There's like, what's it
called?
There was another one for it.
I'm gonna try this out.
It's supposed to help you focus more, but I surprise stream
today because I will be gone on I don't remember what day
I'm fucking gone.
I'll be gone on Friday.
I'll be gone on Friday for the I'm gonna put it on the
schedule, but it's an event.
I'm doing an event with Capcom.
You're hosting a special I don't even know who else is gonna
be there.
I just know that I'm doing, like, a little quiz show at the
Capcom Studio.
And it was going to be on my schedule because I asked them.
So they're flying me to their...
To...
Is this called Studio?
The Capcom Headquarters.
What do you call, like, the...
Is it a studio, like, the...
Yeah, Capcom Studio in America.
Because they invited me to do, like, their promotion.
promotion thing for Oni Mushu.
Oni...
For Oni Musha?
I keep fucking...
Is it Oni Mushu or Oni Musha?
I don't know why.
I keep saying the other one.
Oni Musha.
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah.
Capcom USA.
Um...
Invited me to their studio.
Uh...
To do a special...
Event thing.
For Oni Musha.
For the new...
Uh...
For the release of the...
new Onimusha game.
And it's called, okay, so the tentative title was going to
be called The Biggest Weeb.
So it was like, it's going to be like a little quiz show, a
quiz show game with some other creators there.
And I asked if they could multi-stream it on my channel
because originally it's just going to be on Capcom channel.
Like it was just going to be on the Twitch and the YouTube.
And I also asked if they could multi-stream it on my
channel.
They said, yeah, of course they love to.
So it's also going to be on my channel too because I figured
like, it'll be, uh, yeah, is tentative by the way it might
it might they might change the title so that's why i was
just gonna be like special event with capcon um but you know
no you know that what if i'll surprise everybody on friday
you don't know that you know i'm i'm gonna surprise
everybody with my knowledge I've been to Japan several
times.
It's going to help me.
Maybe they'll have, like, call a friend.
Maybe I'll open up chat on my...
I'll open up chat on my phone.
And...
Nobody said I can't use call chat.
So...
Yeah, I'm just giving Leah a chat.
I was like, ah, yes, I definitely know the answer.
Let me, give me a sec.
Give me five.
I'll, like, buzz the button.
I'm like, I think the answer is that.
That.
That, that, that, like, it's tall.
I, I.
all right that's not suspicious at all i'll be like i'm i'm
just thinking i always talk at this speed
so um uh so yes uh i think it's on friday and yet let me
look at my message like i'm I'm all over the place today.
It's been a not great day for me.
It's been a very, very not so great day for me.
It's been very, very rough.
Okay, I'll be like, wait, is it on Friday?
I double check the day, too.
Anyway, so this game, well, it's not really a game game per
se.
It's like those... I know there's another one that people
use a lot i'm trying to remember what it's called um i just
wanted to use it because it's also like uh so that's like i
don't have to like find a music playlist or some shit it's
called uh okay it is on it is on friday good okay i know
it's on friday so this game is sort of like the other famous
one um that everybody uses and it's called oh my god where
is it i i literally had it up but then i disappeared ah
sorry i'm like I'm really stressed out right now.
I'm really, really stressed out right now.
I like how the tag on this is called relaxing.
I'm anything but relaxed at the moment.
I'm not happy today.
Yeah, Gogg.
Whatever that thing is called.
That's what I was thinking of.
So it's basically similar to Gogg.
But, it's not.
I want to try it out.
Is Sound Guy alive?
I don't know.
I don't know if Sound Guy's alive.
Alright, let me...
I want to customize my character.
Let me customize.
Look, I have you guys.
You guys are here.
Style name.
I'm...
Someone...
In my misery.
Oh.
Alright.
All right, let's see who do I have.
Oh, my God, what a fucking freak you are.
Okay, skin-colored wolves are not, like, great.
Could be a rabbit.
Don't give, you know, like, rabbits can have, like, heart.
Like, don't, don't scare a rabbit, because they'll have a
heart attack.
I'll be, I don't know.
Oh, I'll be a rabbit.
I'll be a...
do I want to be actually nah maybe I don't want to be a
rabbit oh all right all right I'm a rabbit I have to pay for
this I have like a hundred bucks what can I can I get how I
feel right now all right no I don't think rabbits should
have eyebrows hey
okay let's see I am A sad, a very sad rabbit.
Why are they all happy?
I'm there.
Yes.
Alright.
I'm a very sad rabbit.
Alright, what else?
Ooh.
That's cute.
See a little stars.
I feel like it might as well just be like.
Alright, we're just...
Don't worry.
We're gonna do work soon.
We'll do work stuff soon.
Just give me a sec, guys.
all right outfit i got to distract this year over the
weekend so i missed a pre-order for your new merch but i'm
confused why am i still seemingly still able to because we
have an extension congo we have an extension with uh uh with
the birthday merch because i forgot to tweet about it again
so so good news everybody i should i need to tweet about
that too i it got
I will tweet about it guys.
I will tweet about it Um, all right.
No glasses.
That's right.
You're gonna be blind forever Um, all right, this time this
time I will let me customize let me customize first guys
Then I'll tweet about it.
Let me customize my rabbit right now.
I'm sad Let me have this.
I did let me at least have this
And she But alas She still never tweeted about it I'm sad
Just let me fucking customize My fucking rabbit Let me have
this I don't ask for much I don't ask for much Just let me
have this Oh I'm a cute rabbit.
I'm a cute ass rabbit right now.
Yeah.
All right.
Feet.
I'll go with, I mean, shoes.
Oh, that's not shoes.
That's, yeah, I was going to sit.
Oh, no, you're going to know.
Okay, we're going to have yellow shoes.
All right.
Backpack.
Oh, it's.
a froggy backpack oh he just gave him eyes nothing new all
right we'll just wear blue backpack tail well i'm a rat what
do you mean it's fucking dlc rabbit tail what the fuck is
this i'm already a rabbit give me a tail all right outfits
don't have enough i'm just broke right now oh i get a flow
and you're chilling means money and money means happy dokey
that's true can you get it don't worry i'll outsource it can
you guys chill for me thank you for the super chat pop up
thank you thank you there you guys are a pixel games hard
and anyone else in the coop things oh nice see that is huge
dragon there you guys go all right my desk my workable decks
I don't want to say dex.
I'm so angry.
I'm so sad and angry right now.
I-
Rabbit, rabbit, rabbit, hell, area of study.
They are here forever.
about you I want to cry but I can't because I can't work
through these dude I can't see through tears see it through
my tears when I'm working so I gotta suck it up like a big
boy rabbit and
This is...
That's the face of a winner.
Did you know that you can get your own Dookie Bird tomato
boxes right now at the Dookie Bird merch at the Dookie Bird
store?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Solid snake.
There you go, now
Yeah, I'm okay, guys, sorry I'm up, you see, there's a happy
face, you know I'm okay right now, yeah, all right, all
right, play, okay, let us make it How do I...
Alright, let's...
Okay, wait.
Join games.
Is there... Okay, I'll give you guys...
I don't know if you guys will have it.
Let's cry together.
Someone who is okay.
I'm okay.
Wait, sound guy.
We're sound guy.
Sound guy.
Get out of here.
I'm sorry, sorry.
Sorry, sorry.
I will not project my sadness and anger to sound deep on the
screen.
I'm not projecting.
I won't project on to them.
I won't continue the cycle.
All right.
Don't worry.
Oh, don't worry.
I made sure.
Oh, look, there you guys are.
That's so cute.
on my freaking head.
Oh my, there I am.
There I am.
Alright, let's see.
Uh, here you guys go.
That's us.
That's you guys.
You guys have this game.
So the neat thing about this is that I can make it like a
little tiny guy over here.
I thought that was pretty neat.
Look at this tiny little guy over here.
Well, he can't move, though.
He's just there.
So, like, or I could just do, or I do this, or...
Wait, can I... What's this?
Oh, yeah, I can make it bigger.
Or I could do this.
Or I could do...
Uh...
This.
Like, I thought it was cool, so we could, like...
I don't know.
Maybe we'll swap screens later.
Just...
Yeah, anyway, if anyone wants to join the, yeah, I thought
it was pretty neat.
Um, oh my god, there's a cat boy.
Oh my god, they also have a dragon.
And then there's like a freaking fish too.
Well, we, I don't know how to fish.
One year from now, dragon is going to file a mailbox with
Mr. Cell.
So they buy a dog, oh my god.
Hey, if they enjoy it, and I can fish too.
relax and fish on the side um of course it has fishing and
then i can oh oh anything but whoa what did i get oh wait
what did i get i got a carp yay not really seeing that shit.
Give me that.
Now!
My $4!
And then, and then there's, uh, apparently there's like
little mini games that want to like, be productive.
Like, if I don't want to stop being productive, but I can go
over here and I just start reading.
And then if you do this, you do this.
And then it's like a tiny little guy.
Look at them.
He's just reading over there.
Look at the tiny little guy.
He's so tiny.
Look at this tiny little man.
Oh, and I could like move him to like And I could be like,
oh, I can't eat him
It comes to airplane Okay, there you go.
Sorry.
I'm This is my stress relief right now
This is my stress relief at the moment Anyway, so I can I
gotta finish I'm done I'm done focusing I don't uh get me
out oh my god okay give me a second I'm trying to figure out
how to get out I'm done oh yeah there I'm finished there you
go and then I could do it like random like just sit down and
just this is my desk right there um so there's like I'm so
focused I'm just showing you guys around and then I'll start
focusing up I swear to God I'm just showing you guys around.
And then there's also...
Oh my god, wait, you can run?
How do you run?
Am I running?
I can't tell.
Alright, there's like mini games too.
So, oh, this is like...
I guess there's fishing.
I know there's mini games and stuff you can play.
Okay, let me look at the map.
I don't fucking know.
I just got this game.
I...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
There's a tutorial.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
And zoom in and zoom out.
Oh my gosh.
read this.
B to inflate your bubble gum?
Whoa!
Yippee!
Okay, this is like fast travel.
It's fine.
He'll be okay.
And then, what else is there?
Alright, well, sound guy is not alive right now.
Do we have mods?
Do we have mods alive?
I focus to use shortcuts.
Let's see.
Scroll to scale your shift to see players nearby oh that's
cute spend time to focus fish shoot hoops or jam with
friends the more you play the more you earn the right outfit
and is all it takes give them time h to equip nice tap to
view or moderate players turn your oh yeah there's a
pomodoro timer too um i have i have voice chat off by the
way so because i heard about the voice chat feature i made
sure to turn all right whoa you see that oh all right
congratulations you've been demoted onto the basement you go
time to go into the sound guy basement oh shit okay never
mind congratulations you're freed all right all right all
right how's the sound how's the How's the sound right now?
How do I use this?
Oh, whatever.
All right, so a little bunch of little places you can go to
focus and study.
Oh, my God.
Get me out of here.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Where's the hoops?
What the fuck is this?
Okay, those fruits.
I was promised hoops.
Where are the hoops?
I can do that.
I'd be like, why can I just do that?
Let me say hi.
All right, hello.
That's how I feel.
That's me.
I'm trying to fight.
I'm trying to fucking...
Who's up here?
What the fuck?
Oh, he's Zen right now.
Is this anybody?
Is this someone?
Who are you?
Is this an NPC?
I got it.
It's so Zen.
Oh my god, there's the hoops.
There it is.
Oh, there's this random dude that's just vibing.
That's an NPC.
Yeah, I was gonna say, who is that guy?
Wee.
Oh my god, okay, and then we can play B-ball.
Where's b-ball?
Come on.
Come on, pass!
Pass!
Oh my god, I see.
That's right.
Whoa, that's right.
Defend this.
That's it.
I'm a baller.
Oh yeah, watch this.
Oh.
Okay, oh yeah, watch this.
Oh, yeah?
Watch this.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, yeah?
Watch this.
Swish, nothing but net.
Whoa, swish.
Oh, shit.
Rebound.
I did it first try.
Oh, no!
Get out of here, bingas.
Oh, yeah.
Boom, three-pointer.
Oh, three points.
And a crowd goes wild.
Donkey, donkey, donkey.
Four-pointer.
Oh, oh.
shit okay wait wait wait a minute wait a minute foul oh nice
nice all right five pointer right here swish first of five i
won i'm done but i don't think yokey understands that basket
excuse I was the captain of my baller team Is that all the
mini games here?
Is that it?
Just both basketball and It's just basketball and fishing.
I assume there'll be more stuff to do.
Not gonna lie.
It's a full court.
Leaves.
Alright, fishing.
Okay, it's just fishing.
Look, I just wanted to know what this is i just i thought
there would be more it said there were many games but it's
just basketball and finishing well i could play the guitar
and drums let's go i just want to know what else because
it's like it why is there more to this oh my god i can have
coffee um wait i can have cop i can have boba tea give me
that boba tea Look at the girl.
I'm so focused.
Use.
Oh.
No.
I'm...
What the fuck is going on?
Am I... What is going on?
I think we need to go to the health inspector.
I don't think Boba T is supposed to do that.
It's like...
Oh, but now it's like rabbit poop.
Oh, no.
Fix this.
Fix it.
When I say Oh no Everything's going Right I gotta like get
this off Nothing is Fixing it Oh this is bad This is bad Oh
no I don't know how to fix this Oh no This is How do I fix
this?
All I have is cotton candy.
I'm so relaxed.
Oh my god, I got a little dragon seeing out.
Anyone?
Help.
I need to fix this.
This is very protective.
I'm trying to fix this.
I don't know what to do.
I don't want to be it.
I don't want to poop.
This is how you're supposed to use kind of cat.
I thought I was just gonna eat it.
How do I fix this?
Ow!
I try to toggle it up.
Is that...
I have to pay her to fucking remove this.
No, I can't even toggle it up.
That's fucked.
That's a pay here.
it pay her to fix it stop making this sad why is everything
going wrong we please you're making it worse i don't know
what to do what did i do
Okay, does it?
I don't think it counts, guys.
It's not letting me remove anything.
Oh my god, get it off.
Someone gets this off me.
Okay, maybe if I eat it again, it'll work.
I'll put in our $10.
This is fashion now.
There's, like, no context as to what it would do.
What the?
No, I didn't mean to buy it!
I bought it!
Oh, what does this do?
Did I make it worse?
Oh, I bought two.
Oh, I'm already broke.
Oh, that's how I do the Naruto.
Okay, at least I know how to...
Oh, at least I know how to do the Naruto.
run at least.
Oh my god.
It stopped.
I stopped.
I fixed the boba.
The boba stopped.
Oh my god.
Okay.
At least we know how to do the Naruto run.
Now we gotta figure out how to get the beard off.
Okay.
The water removes it.
How do I get the beard off though?
Buy and drink.
Oh it removes the boba.
Does it remove the beard too?
Okay.
Do I have enough money?
Alright.
Oh, yay!
Okay, I still have the...
I want Naruto run.
Okay.
Alright, we figured it out.
I can still do Naruto.
Okay, now we go work now.
We go work for real.
Alright, let's find a place to work, guys.
Alright, what would be a nice place to hang out?
We'll do it.
We'll do it here.
I'm on the beach.
What do I want to do on the beach?
I will.
It's a chore.
I'll start vacuuming the beach out.
Let's just vacuum the beach.
Okay, and then...
Whoa.
Wait, okay, apparently I can make you bigger.
I can be like...
Okay.
I'm gonna vacuum the beach, guys.
Wait, okay, if I swap it here.
And then...
But where is he?
Oh, it's not transparent?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Actually, he might be.
If I put him here, oh, I can't make him transparent.
That sucks.
If I could have made him transparent, just vacuum next to
me.
It's just me.
Be like vacuuming next to me.
Wait, allow...
Oh, I can!
There we go!
Let's have it.
Yeah.
Just have vacuuming next to me.
Wait, let's see.
Or you could be like over here.
Like, guys, do you guys not want to vacuum?
Let's all work together, everybody.
Let's see.
Okay.
all right wait okay how do i i can add other people to my
work area too i'm trying to remember how
uh together we can get rid of the sand exactly all right let
me look at the tutorial again i'll remember the tutorial
start working i guess what together we can clean the sand
guys okay let me remember how to do the screen mode uh
shifts to see press and hold to see all the nearby players
all right how do i do this
oh there we go
is that all of you guys
yeah that's my team my team of vacuum cleaners there's The
gang's all here.
Well, I mean...
Wait, I got an idea.
I have an idea, guys.
I have a great idea.
Let's have them...
Let's see.
Let's get rid of...
And then...
The gang's all here.
Cleaning my desk.
Let's go.
Okay.
The gang's all here.
There we go.
Alright, sweep my desk, guys.
Go sweep my desk.
Where's my chowder?
It is.
Alright.
Where's Chowder down?
It's over here.
Alright, you guys sweep.
We're cleaning.
Here we go.
Go sweep my desk.
Sweep, sweep, sweep.
Is that everybody?
There has to be more of you guys, right?
Okay.
Wait, how do I...
Not...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
He fell asleep.
Is that all of you guys up here?
Let me check.
Oh, it is.
It is all of you guys.
He gave...
of sweeping all right let's see it back over here you go
wait where's my whoops it's supposed to be here and then
there we go
all right oh yeah the code the code is oh my god this is the
code this room isn't gonna clean itself guys come sweep with
me come you too can come sweep sweep sweep sweep I can
actually change the music to here let's see
uh focus meditate I didn't even see what they wrote how do
you sleep focus meditate sleep all right let's see i gotta
there's music yeah there is music guys not hearing the music
i could turn it up a little bit there we go oh hey guys hey
jesus we're here to hang out press f
Vacuum my desk, everybody.
Oh, hey.
I didn't see you.
Where did you come from?
Hey, Sharky.
There, everybody.
Keep vacuuming.
I need you guys to vacuum my desk.
I...
Just hang up.
All right, let's actually start working.
Okay, let me set up a timer.
All right, 25 minute timer, guys.
All right, oh, this is actually, wait, this is actually
pretty cool.
My list.
Stop crying, dokey.
All right.
Wait, this is pretty cool.
Wait, I actually love this.
There you go.
I have to actually get...
Now we're actually getting work done, guys.
Alright.
It's this task planner.
Today was a day.
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
How are you feeling today?
That's how I'm feeling today.
Alright.
Oh yeah, also make merch.
Tweet.
That's a good...
Alright.
Oh wait, we have more people in here now.
Is that everyone?
Oh.
Oh, almost got removed Sharky.
There we go.
Where do we want to play everybody?
We'll play everybody here.
all right guys we got this focus up everyone all right oh
whoops oh i got it oh well wait where did sharky go sharky
disappeared oh there's sharky oh my god i'm so confused oh
oh okay there you go there's everybody sweeping away there
they all are sweeping away you make them even tiny oh my god
i made my chrome tiny i'm trying to make these guys tiny
here all right we'll make them make them giant or we'll make
them here we go guys we gotta keep vacuuming the sand guys
we gotta clean up the dust guys yeah keep vacuuming the sand
everybody all right let's see uh let me make my merch tweet
right now okay we'll put this here so i can see my twitter
account right now no stop scrolling here i'm trying to okay
there you go all right there you go all right it's a little
little rough because uh i didn't realize uh it's all like i
could i see it all here okay all right can bring over up
overall up slightly all right let me know if it's better now
sound guy i could also like i want to do like i don't hear
any of the rain or anything like i don't hear any of the
give me the give me all of this hear all of that sound.
Let's see.
Oh, I have a summer side.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Whoa!
Oh, I fuck with this.
There we go.
The summer studies.
Oh, that's a nice playlist.
Alright, here we go.
Um, Oh, I turned this off.
All right, let me make my merch tweet.
How did I do merch tweet before?
Jokey merch.
Jokey bird.
I can just get the template.
Oh, okay.
It's like we are, I know, it's like we're in the Bahamas
right now.
Guys, I can feel it.
We're like, we're like in the Bahamas, guys.
It's just like the Bahamas, everybody.
All right, let's see.
Just like the Bahamas.
All right, what do we call this?
Bird, Eepie, Bird, La Merch Pre-orders.
Eepie, Birthday, Merch, Pre-orders.
Alright, and then I gotta grab the thumbnails.
I wish I was back in the Bahamas, guys.
If only...
If only I was back in the Bahamas.
Yeah,
I had a really, really rough day.
It was just a very stressful day.
Very, very, very, very stressful day.
That's all I can really say.
It was not ideal.
Not an ideal day for me.
So, I always, that's why, like, I was like, I have to
stream.
I always feel a lot better whenever I'm streaming, too.
So, um, oh, it can be brought back down.
All right, I'll bring it back down.
Let me know if it's better, sound guy.
So, I was like, oh, like, streaming always makes me...
Oh, my God, look, that's me.
Right there.
Oh, my gosh.
What a great artist.
all right uh mondays and my chart this is why i don't stream
i usually don't stream on monday but because i will be i
won't be streaming on saturday i figured i might as well
i'll treat because like i won't be streaming on saturday
because i'll be still be over at uh whatever city the capcom
hq studio is uh oh what's the oh yeah the countdown was
supposed to like my focus session countdown but clearly it's
not really working clearly this is supposed to like be like
this is the timer where i'm supposed to be focused right now
it's up though at least it's up there
and i still wanted to stream but I wanted to be productive
while I'm streaming.
So I was like, I figured I might as well just do like a
working stream because I felt like at least I'm streaming
and I'm also like being productive right now.
So that's why I'm here.
I felt like, I know.
I was like, oh, I could play a game.
And I was just like, I actually have a lot of stuff to get
work on.
But I still want to be able to stream today too.
I
am being productive.
I'm writing my merch tweet right now.
Uh, we have one, one, one week left pre-order.
Um, but if you haven't seen it, um, sweeping in progress.
Am I still sweeping?
I'm still vacuuming.
Uh, uh, you don't know.
We've released, we've released some, eepie, some sleepy
time.
Sleepy-themed merch.
Um.
By merch from tomato boxers to your very own dad blankets.
Alright.
Alright, back to the basement you go.
Your job is done now.
Alright, now we gotta find the thumbnail for this.
Oh no.
Okay, large icon.
Um.
Put this here.
This and this and.
All right.
That should be good.
Oh, you know, now we release some sleepy theme merch from
Timu.
from Jamil boxers with a face on the front or
with a little happy face to welcome you on the ass or front.
See you there.
You on the ass or front.
front okay there you go all right one we like to pre-order
but I don't know we release some some sleepy theme merch
from my birthday on my birthday from tomato boxes a happy
for a little happy face to welcome you on the ass or crotch
okay To welcome you either on the front or back.
But, um, the tomato boxers with two, from two, with two,
from two pairs.
Ah, cat, fucking, I'm dumb.
I feel so dumb right now.
I'm dumb and tired.
Oh my, uh, happy face to welcome you whether you're coming
or going okay whether you're coming or going wait guys
already okay no all right I saw I've got enough for the word
limit thank you guys I really need it I really really need
this I really appreciate everybody here.
Oh, that's a papa.
No, we really slept sleepy theme merch on my birthday from
tomato boxers.
So welcome you whether you're coming or going to your very
own dad blanket.
Or maybe if your very own dragon slippers.
There you go.
I always say dragon slippers.
Alright.
Alright, there we go.
Nice.
by the way i hate absolutely hate the new twitter updates
you guys see the new twitter update where um like where you
click media you have to pick between photos or videos just
show it all i i hate that update so much
it's so annoying yeah like i hate that they killed the media
thing and also like you have to like you can't even see all
the tweets you have to like click all on your own it's so
like i why is the default videos people barely post videos
too it's so bad like I don't get why they have to make it
more complicated it was like keep it simple you know kiss
keep it simple there's no reason for them to make it so
complicated like why do I have to press multiple buttons to
see like all the stuff I want to see they should have made
the default like the choices you know like if I just want
videos I should I should have that as the default not like
um to like see everything like the the choices I make
um but I don't know I should add links I know I should stop
adding links to stuff but like I don't know I feel like if
you wanna like because like apparently adding links affects
the exposure of your tweet So I keep, I don't know, I feel
like I should have just I need to do, I need, yeah, because
like in the past it didn't matter But now like the whole
Twitter algorithm changed So that you always have to add
links as responses But I feel like, I feel like who
actually, who's going to actually like click down below I
feel like less people click down below anyway, like I don't
know It's too many clicks, you know That's the whole thing,
it's just too many clicks to do
I when I see a tweet I just want to click on it on the tweet
itself I'm not gonna click on a tweet just to click on the
link yeah I don't care like it's like yeah I know I know it
gives like um man if you guys want to use the tweet if you
guys like I get it like it exposes the tweet out more to
your followers and you don't put a link on it but i'm like
who is actually going to click on the link like who's
actually going to click on the tweet like who's going to
click on it i don't i'll fucking click on the tweet if i see
it on the tweet i'll click on it like it's stupid it's so
fucking stupid i'm a lazy person please cater to me
Why are they not catering to me?
I clicked it really is.
I would just scroll.
I don't click on it to click on the link.
To be honest, most people wouldn't.
Why are we yelling?
You know what grabs my gears?
Oh, cool.
Yeah, exactly.
Scroll down.
Clicks on the tweet just to access the fucking link.
And a true comes out.
Sorry, I've been really pent up in anger and sadness today.
Let's see.
I'm shooting shots everywhere.
It's like friendly fire.
Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang.
Let's see I know I should be tweeting out my waiting room
And then I have to put the link in below But like I said
Who's fucking clicking on the tweet to access the waiting
room Just have it there I hate the new I hate change I hate
the new meta I hate the new meta Why is this the new fucking
meta?
It doesn't make sense.
Nothing makes sense anymore.
Why is nothing good for lazy people?
That's what I'm saying.
It should be, like, more accessible to the lazy people out
there.
Me!
It should be more accessible Why
They are this I know I'm getting discriminated on Like She's
just like me for real For real Like why do I have to do more
work I'm on your website already I'm not here to be
productive.
I'm already on your website.
What more do you want?
the lazy lives matter.
Like, it's, you're right.
It's more like efficiency.
Why can't you be more efficient?
Oh, sorry.
I'm a little, I'm like, wagy-ragy right now.
But, like, I'm my own boss.
If it ain't broke, Exactly.
Let me make my...
Oh yeah, Palworld will be up for another month, by the way.
Exciting news!
We're gonna...
We're gonna have Palworld servers up for another month,
because I didn't have time to...
Because it's supposed to... It should have ended, like,
tomorrow, but then we didn't really...
Have, like, time to...
To really do...
You know, I was gone for one week for vacation, and then
when I came back, I was also...
Pretty tired.
Yeah.
So, so it's gonna be up for another another month.
By the way, is it sound better?
Or like, because like I did, I did like, I don't know.
The song is a bit louder.
So I hope the music is not overpowering.
All right, let me upload.
I'm gonna make a YouTube community post now.
I don't even know when the actual pre-order.
I should actually look that up.
Okay.
The Dragonwood member server, by the way, I'm talking about.
I had a sloppy one.
Sorry, you're going to be up for whatever they want to...
They stop.
Whenever I find out they stop playing on it.
Then it's going to be.
Then I'll take it down.
I'll give a warning obviously.
It won't be like.
Surprise.
Gone now.
But I'll give them a warning.
Oh I'm dumb.
I forgot to link the actual birthday.
I mean when you click on.
I should have linked the actual.
Link directly towards.
Towards.
the sleepwear instead of just doky merch.
Whatever.
Okay, I'll be like...
The EP merch.
Alright.
I'll do it here too.
Fuck it.
EP merch?
As a reply.
Alright.
I've just been so stressed out.
Oh yeah, by the way, I need to retweet it too.
Vexpo for EU Dragons.
EU Dragons.
So you guys didn't know, we did a little 20-minute mini
concert because it's like the opening concert for Vexpo with
Doobie.
So we're doing something a little special.
So basically, we are producing a mini three-year-old
20-minute concert where people were attending the Vexpo
opening concert.
Right?
We're working on that.
I took full response.
I'm paying for all of it.
We're splitting on other stuff, but I told Doobie, like,
hey, I'm cool with finding the entire cost just because it
was something I really wanted to do.
But do not worry.
Don't worry about the FOMO or anything.
We will upload it onto YouTube later on.
So for those who are like, no, FOMO, I'm not your...
Now you know how the European goons feel.
Now,
now you know how they feel.
Like, with all the concerts in NA.
Now you know how they feel.
Yeah, it's so true.
They just like a crumb of what they can't have in NA.
you get the European experience.
I'm glad they feel this every day.
These don't happen.
What about the Latin American goons?
What about the Asian goons?
So, so, European goons, if you are going to Expo, especially
on the opening concert.
I think that's on Friday.
September 18th.
Oh, I don't remember the dates, guys.
I'm sorry.
I'll replace it.
September 18th.
And you go to the opening concert.
Duby and I are doing a 3D concert for it.
It's a mini 3D concert.
It'll be like, there's other performers.
There's other performers there, but for Duby and I section,
it will be 3D.
and I'm not gonna spoil the set list too much but we're
making it European themed because we're in a European we are
in a European um European concert or like it is a European
convention so there might be uh there might be a few songs
in there that are specifically European themed as in like
that uh you might recognize as a european
so just a little bit of like oh oh uh just a little bit like
a little uh little spoiler of the set list
uh but yeah but we will upload we will upload the uh the
concert because it's like a mini con it's like 20 minutes
like that's like our section like we have 20 minutes a
segment of this opening up like i said there's a lot of
other performers there i want to make it a little special
for you guys uh because it's like a one little thing i'm
doing at uh vexpo so uh it will be uploaded later on uh to i
don't know if it's gonna be both our channels it was just
gonna be my channel like half half uh but we'll see we'll
see we're still figuring it out like how we're gonna upload
it but it will be uploaded online later like i'm investing
more than what i was paid to peer at Vexpo.
Because it's 3D.
It's a 3D concert.
But I just want to do something special.
Because I know I'm basically I'm basically like I'm not
breaking even on it or anything.
It's just something I want to do special for the European
dragoons.
Because you know, I don't get to do a lot.
Like there's only really only like two conventions in Europe
that like invite VTubers.
I mean it's getting bigger.
It's getting bigger and bigger but like at right now there's
only two conventions right now that are that invite vtubers
and i and i want to do like something a little special for
the european dragons there because they're not all
opportunities to go to vtuber events uh for you guys so it's
just a little thing like a special thing um and i'm really
happy that dubie agreed to my crazy plan slash idea like i
felt so bad i was like i'm so sorry because she was like oh
i thought we were just gonna be our like, you know, like the
usually some of the concerts just like the our skin suits
like, oh, I thought we were just gonna be 2D and like just
like sort of like semi-cariaqui and I was like, but do be
like do be out.
It's gonna be so much cooler if we do it.
It's okay.
I'll pay for it.
It's gonna be so much cooler if we do it on 3D, you know,
it's gonna be so exciting.
And she's on my wild ride and I felt so bad.
Like I'm so sorry for dragging you into this crazy plan I
have.
I'm so sorry.
She's like, no, I think I love it.
I was like, I'm sorry.
I was like, but, oh my God, but it's going to be so fun,
Jimmy.
She was like, wait, I thought we were just going to be 2D.
I was like, but what if we're 3D?
What if, but Jimmy, what if we're 3D though?
So, um, so, shout out to Doobie for being on my wild ride.
Like, she, shout out to Doobie.
Uh,
for putting up with my crazy plans.
Okay, but hear me out.
4D, though.
Alright, let me make.
my epi birthday merch priorities um
how i haven't made a community post right about it i know i
haven't i've been going through so many things i know i have
yeah uh
announced birthday on my epi filled Burr, Bind, Bind.
They merch.
Build.
Oops.
You guys can't even see the dragon plush anyways.
I'll put it away.
Sound guy.
I did lower the music a little bit more.
Let me know you want me to lower even more.
Or those on a screen.
They're everybody.
They're all working hard.
For those who are like, what's that?
I mean, look.
We're all just...
Oh, wait, there's more of you guys?
We're just...
We're just hanging out.
We're just working and hanging out together.
If you guys want to work and hang out with us, this is the
code.
Let's see.
The NEPFIL themed birthday merch.
Um...
Wait, why did it reset itself?
Oh!
What?
Did I already took my short break?
What happened?
Did it already gave me a break?
I didn't focus.
Oh, it's the code for the game.
This is the game.
It's called... On Together Virtual Co-working.
You guys want to virtually work in there.
I worry.
Yeah, we took a break.
When did that happen?
What do you mean, doobie?
I turned myself 3D.
I'm in 3D, doobie.
I'm 3D dookie.
Mr. Broken Bun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Now it's an EP filled birthday.
Uh, merch drop.
To boxing.
Tomato boxers.
We have tomato boxers Where you can get Choose Where it
comes with Comes with two pairs Face on the front Or the
pack Depending on how you're feeling Today Where the face is
on the front Or back Depending on how you're feeling today.
I also have Dragoon slippers.
Dragoon.
Slippers.
Um.
And dad.
Dad blanket.
There's only one week left to pre-order.
And then it's gone forever.
Wow.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Okay, there we go.
And I'll make another tweet to be like, Last day!
Alright.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Bada-dum, Bada-dum.
Why do I feel so tired?
I shouldn't feel this tired.
I think it's just from the stress, honestly.
Here's the tweet if you guys want to Give it a little Give
it a little bit of a signal boost Out there Okay what else?
Alright Nice.
So We did it Um What should I do I have to do I should have
a lot of stuff I should write down all this stuff Well I
will answer DMs And then they're just like, answer DMs.
Answer that DM.
Answer this DM.
It can't be so separate to be fair.
So you just answer this one and then answer that.
Let's see.
what else do i have to do don't stream yourself working
takes off some of the stress so let's chill for us as nice
as yet the one i'm glad it's chill for you guys oh yeah make
schedule let's make the schedule now all right so let me get
pull up my calendar right now um okay i'm gonna put my
calendar my second monitor just because uh these little guys
is a little bit distracting To be fair.
Oh, wait, okay.
Let me...
We're gonna take you guys off a little bit.
I'm gonna put you on my other monitor.
Let me put you guys on my other monitor.
Because I...
I'm trying to, like, type stuff, but you're covering half my
screen while I'm trying to type right now.
It's not very ideal for me.
Alright, let me put you on monitor...
2.
Alright.
There we go.
Yeah.
I'm gonna put you on mine or two.
So I can actually, like, see what I'm typing.
Alright.
Let's see.
There we go.
It should be fine.
Nothing really changes.
Bum, bum, bum.
Alright.
Boom.
So you're still here.
Still just...
Chilling.
I'm so confusing.
Because my Opie is still...
is there too now oh my god me this is a little worse for me
i'll put my obs uh oh my okay i'm putting my obis here okay
schedule maybe i can get fourth monitor honestly
let's see
um all right so tomorrow i actually uh let's do a choicer
voicer on Twitch on Wednesday.
Choicer Voicer Wednesday.
And then, where's my Discord?
Here it is.
Alright, it is on Friday.
Friday 2pm.
Okay, Friday 2pm on special event with Capcom.
At Capcom At CapCon studio.
Is it studio?
Like games?
Is that what they're called?
Like game studio?
Like Riot Studio?
Is it studio?
Like the the HQ?
I don't remember like the...
I don't remember the proper term.
I'm like really brain dead today.
I'm actually pretty brain dead right now.
It's just called studio.
Yeah.
Like, game, dev.
And so,
I never, like, my brain's not used to working on Monday,
honestly.
Capcom Tower.
It's Monday, guys.
It's still Monday for me.
wait i should have to use the bathroom i'll be right back
guys just go keep vacuuming the beach
all right i'm back guys i am back oh is my shit right now
all right back to being productive
okay duck solid broku top stuff bite rice shadow zekrametti
space nexi vincel uh papa they give a super chat thank you
thank you back to work i go i'm okay i'm okay
all right yay i gotta i gotta i got a i got 100 i got 100 my
dog gift card for my trip to Capcom.
Nice.
I don't have to pay for transportation.
Let's go.
They gave me a gift card for when I'm traveling.
Yippee.
I like that.
I like free stuff.
I like
sponsored I mean technically it is I'm like promoting
Onimusha I like Onimusha
I was gonna say why was there an uber gift card in my email
I was gonna say it was you know like the uh ma'am I need you
to buy a $20 Amazon gift card right now so I can access your
bank account I was like why did I get this
Hey, you've been hacked, ma'am.
Please buy a $20 gift card right now on Amazon.
Don't redeem it.
Yeah.
All right, let's see.
Oh, yeah, schedule.
We'll do Twister Voicer on Twitch because I learned my
lesson.
But for those who are worried about the VOD, it's okay.
The VOD only got demonetized.
Nothing else.
nothing else happened to it other than it getting
demonetized so we're okay we're safe was a little was
definitely a little bit crazy of me through a little bit too
close to the sun and streaming it on youtube a little wild
that day that i did that yeah uh team uh thank you for
Unfortunately, I hate to break it to you.
I cannot read.
So I have to put this on.
I can only speak and listen to Cantonese.
So I'll have to put this on translate.
Oh, I know it's like all something, something, something,
something, something, something, something, something,
something, something, something, something,
hern-gong-gong-gong-gong.
I know how to read hern-gong-gong.
Yes, I know how to speak Cantonese.
But I don't know how to read.
I don't know how to read.
I don't know how to read Cantonese.
I'm not that good.
It's a long time ago.
I live in Canada.
I don't know how to speak a lot of Cantonese.
Uh, I almost 10 years, 8 years.
8 years.
I'm like, I'm like, I don't know the word I'll say in
English.
I think I'm going to return to Hong Kong.
I've been like eight years.
I don't have time to go back.
I don't have time to go to Hong Kong.
It's been a long time ago.
I don't know so many people who know Cantonese.
I think I only know one person who know Cantonese.
Um.
But he's not like, I have a really big, I have an accent.
My accent, my can't, for those who don't know, my accent,
my Because I have a lot of tones, my tone isn't so good.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm talking to my, I'm not saying.
It is, there is.
It's because I do tones.
I do tones and stuff.
I, I do English tones.
I don't do, I don't do like, uh, actual Cantonese tones.
Because I, I never had like a actual, like, I never had an
actual, formal Cantonese education because I went to
international school and then I only learned Cantonese from
my parents and watching TVB and Pearl and World I don't
remember, I remember TVB yeah, I really was a name for TVB
in Cantonese but I don't remember but I literally got better
at speaking Cantonese only from my parents and just watching
TVB
yeah like super I love Super growing up.
Oh, and Steven Child.
Joe Sing-Chi.
Um, I've seen a lot of Joe Sing-Chi-Chi.
And, um, and TVP, TVB, Pearl, Pearl, it's Gwairo, but it's
not Gwairo, but it's Gwairo.
Okay, so you guys don't know what Gwairo is.
I, I should not use that word often because it's
Oigong-Gwairo, because Gwairo is slang.
It's, it's slang.
for a foreigner but it means it means ghost person like but
yeah it's it's it's slang for ghost people but like my
parents used it all the time and it's like it's like at that
back then it was everybody would use it so yeah it's like
guyjin basically so the formal way of saying
young but like because i was raised to the phrase guaylo i
always use it because it was so common back then but i don't
know if it's if you could say it a lot this now yeah like
yeah white like a ghost yeah so direct translation is ghost
people because they're like white like a ghost that
It's just a, it's a very casual, it's like, it's a slang.
Next scene, thank you, super chat, thank you, thank you,
thank you, no, I'm not, I'm swear, I'm not, I'm swear.
Was I being racist?
I know several of them praying for this voice back that you
was super chat, thank you, thank, wait, wait, my parents,
yeah, I was saying I was my parents and like even like
people on TV they will always use that word
but it's like when you I never realized what the direct
translation of it is until like a couple of years later when
I like until like I think like five to six years ago when I
said it on stream and people in chat were like, Doki!
And I was like, what?
They were like, Doki!
And I'm like, what?
I didn't think about the direct translation.
It's very common.
It's a very common word.
Um...
but like uh um but yeah uh for those who are new here who
don't know because like Um,
like, I said, it's like, I spent most of my time, uh, well,
I spent half, I think like, I spent half in Shenzhen, half
in Shenzhen, half in Shenzhen, and half in Hong Kong.
So it's like, yeah, so it's like, uh, it's like my dad's
side spoke Mandarin and my mom's side spoke Cantonese, but,
um, I didn't learn a lot of Mandarin because my parents were
like, you don't need to learn Mandarin.
Like, it's okay.
You can learn French.
You don't need to learn Mandarin.
You can learn French in China.
learn Mandarin.
Instead of French in China.
Yeah.
So I ended up like my Mandarin accent is so bad.
My Mandarin is really, really bad.
Because I have a huge accent trying to speak Mandarin.
I can listen and hear Mandarin.
Yeah, I went to China to learn French.
Exactly.
I had French tutors in China, and I took French classes.
How's my French?
I forgot a lot of my French.
I can, like, listen to, like, a bit of French, like,
conversational style.
I can, like, listen to a bit of French.
But, like, I'm not, like, super fluent anymore.
Like, I learned French for...
Um, so I'll also, Tina, I know exactly what you're typing
out.
I'm not gonna say it.
Budge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Once again, do get Chris.
You call me a.
Bye.
Budge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The thing is, I don't really need it.
I don't use French.
That's the thing.
Bro is in the trenches.
I hope that answers your questions.
I know I haven't spoken a lot of Cantonese lately, but I
haven't really had a chance to bring it up.
You know?
I haven't really had a chance to apply it.
Uh...
was that oh yeah schedule time special event at capcom
studio um what
do i want to do on tomorrow i noticed i want to do the other
endings for i could do it on thursday armor core we'll do a
should we do it early we'll do an early 12 30 stream long
stream of armor core on thursday And just try and get at
least one ending done.
Yeah, I don't get to speak Cantonese often anymore.
So it's like...
I don't know.
I do want to go back to Hong Kong for a vacation.
But it's like...
I need like time.
Why is there a blue person in my room?
Like I...
I just noticed...
Who invited this?
Why are you blue?
Why?
I just noticed that.
I just noticed a blue man.
him.
That's just there.
So why are you blue?
He's like a little ditto.
Whoa.
What's wrong with blue people, Doki?
He's naked.
That's what's wrong.
Not only because he's blue.
He's not wearing clothes.
You're focusing on different things.
at least the blue man grew more close
all right what do i want to do tomorrow i want to do
something like chill tomorrow honestly well not chill this
is the chill stream um but i want to do something uh
more there's so many friends i feel like I feel like this
year meta for streams is roguelike and friend slop.
Every new game coming out is usually a friend slop game or
is a roguelike game, which I've noticed.
Oh, yeah, we have a big walk collab planned, but I don't
think, I think it's like after Mint comes back from...
her uh like i know i say i travel a lot but mint travels so
much i don't know how she does it and keeps up with
everything i cannot i could barely keep up with stuff i just
came back from my vacation i just wish i was on vacation
again like i wish i was back in the Bahamas yeah unholy
thank you and super chat thank you thank you since we're on
subject countenance have you ever been done uh around to
perform the what is that um thank you and super chat unholy
thank you Thank you.
Oh, the tomb sweeping day.
Yes, I have.
I have done that when I used to live in China.
I've done that, like, every year.
Because you guys know how, like...
Wait, that's Cantonese, not Mandarin.
Masaya, see you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, ho, ho.
Is that...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh.
Like I said, I can't read too.
Telling to me in Chinese, I'm putting it in Google
Translate.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Something name, something, something.
Very lovely lady.
Thank you.
I feel like I'm very vulgar lady.
More like vulgar lady.
Oh, am I right?
um but thank you for the super chat thank you thank you was
i oh yeah no i i've done it like i used to live in um china
um um we would do it every year um i remember okay i i
remember one time because for those who don't know the tomb
sweeping uh tomb sweeping day is like held uh once a year
visit the graves of your ancestors or your relatives or your
grandparents or your and like you're anyone who's passed
away that within your family and it's basically you uh you
clean the graves uh and you have you burn paper money and
you do offerings and stuff like that um and I thought it was
it was really interesting because you can tell when uh in
the past it used to be just paper money but as the years go
by like when you um as the years go by technology became
more relevant and more prevalent in society you started
burning paper iPhones and paper computers and that was so
interesting yeah you can buy because then like uh my real
like you know my parents and like I would do it with my
parents my grandparents and my uncles and aunts and uh you
would start and uh they're like print this iphone for your
grandma that was like is it paper iphone i was like you know
when iphone started coming up there you can start they were
there was like paper iphone's i thought it was super
interesting how like uh because it's like when you're
burning these you're giving your uh you're doing it's more
so like uh for when you burn it it goes towards your
relatives or your family members who passed away and who
used these in the afterlife too yeah so there i remember i
would burn gold bars uh paper money uh and i remember i once
burned a paper iphone or a paper uh laptop uh for my grandma
and uh and then i i thought the most interesting thing i
remember asking this because there was like Um, I remember
asking this, uh, why we were burning it, burning extra paper
money on the side, like not just in the designated area, uh,
because you're also supposed to burn stuff on the side to
protect your grave.
So the spirits around, like the spirits that are roaming
around would be satisfied.
You're piecing the spirits around outside of just your, uh,
family member.
uh and they will protect uh your grave as well so i thought
that was like an interesting that i thought that was really
interesting um and yeah so and there was also uh what else
what else what else do we do during it i haven't done it a
long time so um it's it has been a while like i said i
haven't been back for like eight plus years uh yeah there's
food off to do food offerings as well usually like fruit
like mandarin apples um home cooked meals uh just to remind
like because i would we would do it for my grandma um
because she was like the first family member that passed
away um so every time i went it was for my grandma um so
yeah chicken as well yeah whole chicken uh and everything
and liquor yes yes my grandma used to love to drink so A lot
of alcohol.
We know, so she can have alcohol in the afterlife, you know?
So she can also have some in the afterlife.
So we bring a lot of alcohol, too.
I don't know.
I'm trying to remember what else we would do.
Yeah, Granny knows what's up.
It was a full bottle.
I think it was a full bottle.
celebration you know like a like just well not i don't think
celebration is the right word it's like a uh to like honor
your family members and stuff i don't think celebration is
not the right word it's like more so like to honor them and
to remember them and um making sure like you know we still
remember you it's like a tradition yeah it's a gathering
yeah a remembrance day So I've only done it for my grandma.
You spray the alcohol on the ground and just offer the whole
thing.
I remember we spray, we pour it out on the ground and then
we leave it.
And remember, that's how we did it.
Like I said, it's been a long time, so I'm like trying to
remember exactly like what we do.
Yeah, she's enjoying the afterlife.
She is.
But, um, I did participate in Tomb Sweeping Day.
And then, oh yeah, I talked about this before.
Oh yeah, also, yeah, light a cigarette too.
Yeah, you also, you know, so...
She's a cool grandma.
So I also light a cigarette for her.
I remember, like, they...
I remember my uncle would do that for her, too.
But yeah, I remember I talked about this before.
But...
But, um...
So...
this was in shenzhen so for i i don't know so this is what i
was taught or uh taught about during uh tomb swimming day
but the higher usually okay so you know how cemeteries in in
na it's just flat you know it's just like a cemetery like
everything's flat you might get a mausoleum or something but
i don't know if this is just like i don't know if this is
chinese culture or Chinese tradition regarding like
cemeteries.
But in Shenzhen, it was, yeah, it's in the mountains.
Yeah, in China, it's in the mountains.
So the higher you are to the sky, like the higher, like, the
higher, like, it's like, it's better to be on the tallest
peak of the mountains, basically, if when you're getting
buried in China.
Yeah, because it's built on the hillside and everything.
Yeah, the higher your status so you're closer to heaven, you
know
So like I remember it was like a bit funny, but when my
grandma passed away My family bought the highest mountain to
bury her, but then a couple years later They they built a
they built a new cemetery on a hot they made the mountain
higher years later, they made the mountain higher.
So like, we weren't at the highest peak anymore.
Because now they made the mountain higher.
They released the, yeah.
They released the DLC.
Yeah.
How did they do it?
Because I remember they're like, I remember my family would
complain about it if you're like they made they made more
like yeah
they car creeped in the mountains
really hot firecress I remembered I remembered like my
family got really mad about it when they started building
the mountain higher because they spent obviously obviously
you know the higher you're buried the more expensive is
because you know it's the saddest thing and you want you
know like i said like the closer you're to heaven you know
they want they want my grandma to be closest to heaven um
and then so my i remember my family got really mad of really
mad annoyable because it paid so much to to to um to
guarantee a spot to be on the highest part of the mountain
just for them to make the mountain even higher.
Like to make more grave, like make more spots at higher
peak.
Yeah.
Yeah, I know it's true.
What's more important is coming to visit.
Doesn't matter how nice the grave it is.
That's so true.
Yeah, I love to visit my grandma's grave.
again one day in the future um but i guess i haven't been
back in a long time i do want to be go back one day well
obviously like i hope i i hope like as in like soon sooner
rather than later because that's been a while i do sometimes
get homesick um but it's just like maybe next year like i've
been so busy traveling and everything too lately with a lot
of other stuff it's been really hard finding time to like
make such a big trip overseas as well it's been a while
since i made like a yeah i i do i would love to go back one
day
yeah finally caught on your streams live in a while might be
unexpected i really enjoy watching play heroes of mighty
magic 3 a few months back thank you for super chat fam thank
you thank you yeah it's one of my favorite games growing up
i'm glad you guys you enjoyed watching it um I'm not gonna
be able to play for it, but I grew up with like a few games
A few of my dad's hand me downs growing up So So here's what
my magic was one of them Magic, my magic 3 specifically And
Starcraft I think those were the two games that my dad gave
me as a hand me down to play And I always play because I
wasn't allowed on the internet Like my PC back then Was not
connected to the internet Like my own personal PC that I
have So, like, I was only able to, like, play video games
from Costco back in the day where you could buy, like,
those, like, Costco, like, the humongous entertainment and
the Blues Clues Treasure Hunt or, like, the math games and
everything.
And also StarCraft and Heroes of Might and Magic 3.
So, yeah, so those were, like, I would spam StarCraft and
Heroes of Might and Magic 3 all the time growing up.
uh bam thank you for the super chat thank you thank you i
was wondering if you'd be interested in playing here's what
might a magic olden era the new game in the series that's
currently in early asses it even has uh budding capacity in
a competitive competition is something you're well known for
i'm gonna get absolutely destroyed i don't think bam i i'm
gonna get absolutely destroyed when it comes to thinking
games it's just don't make one move and then it's over one
move it's like it's like yukio and i draw pot of green and
another pot of green and another pot of green it's trist
call i'm gonna say corn taxi instead of yellow taxi see
wait that has to mean something Oh, you almost got me.
You almost got me.
I had to say it in my head.
NSD.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For those who don't know.
Okay.
For those who don't know, corn means so corn.
To say corn in Cantonese is so my.
Now what do you think that?
What do you think that sounds like?
The corn is so my and then taxi, taxi, and you're just gonna
splice it together.
I'm not even gonna fucking say it.
I like got him.
And then you post a clip of like the fucking like me
splicing it together.
And be like, so my and then dot dot dot dot dot dot dot dot
dot taxi.
And he put it together.
Got him.
Danny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The jump cut.
So you're thinking games and being Chinese.
When you're playing mahjong.
I actually don't know how to play mahjong.
I only like, I watch so much mahjong.
I don't know what they're doing.
I just know they're like, you know, like the shuffling of
mahjong where they're like shuffling the tiles and shit.
Like, they're like the, oh, but that's like ASMR.
I love the ASMR of them.
I've seen so much mahjong, but I've never actually know what
the fuck they're doing.
Yeah.
I don't know what they're doing.
I watched so much mahjong growing up.
I just don't know what they're doing, but I love the sound
of them shuffling it.
I- Well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Tokyo.
I'm going back to college.
I'm taking old chem again.
Can I get good luck?
Of course, Quell.
Good luck, Quell.
Good luck in chemistry.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We taught Medi Maja and we could teach you.
Rice, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I can finally stop LARPing as Chinese.
If I learn Maja, I can finally stop LARPing.
I'm so, I will say, I'm a very, I'm very whitewashed.
I'm I'm like a banana.
Alright, let's see.
Oh yeah, I've seen old era.
Yeah, I'm yellow on the outside.
White in the inside.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, okay.
I need to figure out what I want to do tomorrow.
What do I want to play tomorrow?
I'm trying to figure out my schedule, guys.
How much?
Oh my gosh, I'm going to stream with two hours.
Let's see.
What do I want to do tomorrow?
Oh, did you guys hear?
Speaking of like, uh, um, Chinese.
Do you guys hear about the new Chinese film about the cows?
For those who don't keep up with, uh, uh, keep up with stuff
on Twitter.
Have you guys heard about the Chinese cow animation?
Okay, so basically, uh, for those who don't know about it,
uh, we've in China we finally have the Chinese the room
movie equivalent like almost equivalent to that so uh let me
see I saved the bookmark like the whole explanation for it
because I don't know if I can explain it properly so so
there is a new movie that just came out it's an animated
film and uh it was known as the lowest box like the lowest
like amount money a movie has ever earned at first for the
first week um but then yeah in that for nine days only 236
people bought tickets to see a 2026 chinese animated film
and it set the years lowest theatrical growth gross but then
people posted on um i guess it was like doyu people posted
on doyu which is like i think it's chinese tick tock and um
and it was it was it was made by a two-man team of a son and
a mom um and and it took like a couple years to make and
they didn't even set up movie posters they had like like
movie theaters had to draw uh oh sorry don't is it doyen
sorry doyen and then they like theaters had to draw posters.
The staff had to the staff at the movie theaters had to draw
movie posters to advertise the film.
And it got so viral through word of mouth and has now become
the most profitable movie in China.
Like return investment.
The most profitable return of investment in China because of
how viral it went.
And it's basically like basically a story like the
equivalent to the room in NA So this is what the movie looks
like Basically the the mom and son team yeah, it was like it
went so it went to the loop of so bad it became so good It
went so viral in China and the thing is is that People are
watching it because they're like oh Like it's like a passion
project, you know, it's a passion project between a mom and
a son and they're like not made with AI or anything it's all
hand animated and took a couple years for them to make or oh
yeah and then here are the movie posters I love the movie
posters the most and
the movie posters my favorite part all right here's more
clips of it I think I read that I think it read that they
basically used animation, like a 10 year old animation
program that was made 10 years ago too.
Just...
I think the postage are my favorite part.
Not gonna lie.
Oh, here are more clips.
I love the clips of these.
I actually want to watch this on a member stream in the
future.
it has soul yeah exactly it has the soul that ai could not
replicate that ai slab will never be able to make
i hope it releases on streaming services because i would
want to watch this with you guys which i even made with
animation software but civil engineering software
would be like how hard they're like let's try to make a
animated film with the worst software possible
the fact that oh i love this one wait i love doing look at
this just the position look at this oh
my god where did i save it look at this just the position
with the movie posters
I know what film I'm watching I know
which one I'm gonna go watch
Spider-Man could never and in this like compilation of all
the posters
look at those abs
holy shit okay here's we're using you a update about the
movie um so apparently the budget was only 10 000 yuan 10
000 yuan really okay too that's that's like that's what so
the budget for this film was was a thousand five hundred us
dollars by the way that is a thousand five hundred us
dollars and it ended up making 9.7 million yen.
Wait, and today, oh my god, 17 million, wait, how much is
that?
17 million, 17 million yen to USD.
So it made, it made $2,500,000 off of a 1.5k budget.
Oh my god The return That's optimized Profit right there
That was worth Five years of production They should release
this In NA I demand them to release this In NA theaters I
want to watch this In IMAX In Canada I don't even know what
the movie is about.
I just know there's a cow in there.
I need a blue ray.
I need this on Netflix.
Stat.
Put this on Netflix and YouTube streaming.
Why would you want them to waste their earth?
They can make more.
They can make, imagine they can make more money.
I would like a 8K 3.5 the IMAX experience, please.
Wait, is it actually already on YouTube?
Yeah, but is it like the actual...
Yeah, but I want the HD version.
I don't want, like, the cam rip, you know?
We need a watch along.
We absolutely need a watch along.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, they...
I deserve...
Like, this movie deserves to be watched in full HD.
Not via cam rip.
Della, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um, have you considered doing a guaranteed demonetization?
No, stream where you get all, get it all.
Sorry, I really would like to keep my channel.
Della, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I like to, I like to keep my channel.
Thank you for the 50 gifted ships!
Oh my god, holy shit!
Thank you!
Thank you for the huge support, though.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I need to do a member stream.
We'll do a double stream on Wednesday.
We'll do a member stream in the morning, in the afternoon.
Sorry, in the afternoon.
The afternoon is my morning.
We'll do Palworld.
We'll visit Palworld.
Wait, did I do a member last week?
Yeah, we didn't do Members Powell World this week, so...
We'll do a Members Powell World in the afternoon on
Wednesday, and then...
I don't know what to do on Tuesday, so...
So I have to figure that out.
Thank you again!
For the 50 gifted ships, I really appreciate it.
Thank you!
I was thank you so much for the support.
Uh...
Why do I want to play?
I want to play something like...
And turn off my brain.
I don't even know if I thought you did all your work and
you're just relaxing.
So, Joki, tell the class all the work you've done.
I made one work tweet and one YouTube community post.
I shall now take a five-hour break.
Job, well done, Joki bird.
Time to take a 10-hour break till tomorrow.
I did it I worked so hard guys Hard working out here Whoa, I
might have to slow down With all the work I'm doing Whoa I
might need to calm down there Might be going down Too hard!
I'm not gonna have to go to the Bahamas again!
Let's see.
I don't know.
I'm just... I don't know what I want to do tomorrow,
honestly.
Because I don't want to play anything too intense.
I also don't want to play something too chill.
Because I've done a lot of chill stuff the last couple of
days.
That'll be a bit of a...
Like, I'll be a bit of a gamer.
Something a bit gamery, but, like, not too gamery.
Because I don't really want to play...
Like, I don't know if I want to play Rank for a Rank game.
I feel like I have been playing less Rank, but it's also
because, like, there's nothing really that's been, like,
motivating to, like, climb for, in a way.
I haven't really been motivated to, like, climb Elo in a
while.
I feel like IMO I feel like competitive games in general
have been slowly like not dying out but like people aren't
really making more competitive like there's not hasn't been
a lot of like interest in competitive games lately in
general for it I feel like I feel like there hasn't been a
lot of games in general um that people play just to be
competitive yeah we're in like a little bit of like uh lull
period yeah it's
been the same ones yeah it's been like the same ones over
and over again there hasn't been anything like new and
exciting that's been like capturing i mean i know there's
deadlock but like the thing about deadlock is that it's ever
changing it's not you know oh but you're like oh rive has
changed all the time but it's like it's still consistent and
what you know um but like i've heard like deadlock changes a
lot and it's because it's still on like bait it's still beta
like it's still on the uh beta so it's not actually like
fully out as to what it is so each month it changes and it's
for me like i i don't have the time to relearn every every
month you know what i'm saying you know what i'm saying i
don't have time to relearn a game in a competitive game
every month like it's why i can always go back to overwatch
and play rank and just be like i can like i can slide back
in you know i can slide back into overwatch rank despite
like i haven't played in a while i can still slide back in
and same with like um same with like apex i can slide back
in if i need to i just need to figure out like i just have
to like be like what's the meta guns oh it's these okay i'm
good and then i just learn the meta guns that's it and then
rivals so i could just slide back in if i heard deadlock
changes every month
so it's like for me i don't know if i want to learn it when
it changes every month and also i'm so oh my gosh it the one
thing is that it's a mova it's yeah i agree it's very hard
for the mainstream I agree so I feel like oh what's the word
a dry period is that what's what's the word when it feels
like um like we haven't really had like a like I feel like
I've played a lot of competitive games only because like
there's not a lot of competitive games that like been like
making it super yeah we're sort of in a little bit of
low-key like a content drought yeah Like a little content
drought right now.
I feel like right now it's Friend Slop.
At the moment it's Friend Slop and Rogue Lights.
That's really popular.
Oh my god.
I don't know if anybody watches.
It's Timmy.
But like Timmy has been doing this.
I think it's so funny.
Not for him.
He doesn't think I find it funny.
Obviously the streamer doesn't find funny.
But anyone that watches who doesn't know about what's going
on with this streamer called his name is it's Timmy And he's
doing this thing where he's trying to get to the highest
rank possible in highest rank possible in like I think like
seven or eight plus competitive games And he's so he
completed CS and apex so you got the highest rank possible
and the highest rank possible and face it in CS and he's
been on he's now on Rainbow Six Siege but he's been on
Rainbow Six Siege for two plus months now he's he's on he's
on game number three but it's been two plus months now and
he's still in diamond he's oh yeah yeah he's been he's been
I think I'm like I would like check out his stream every
couple of weeks just to be like how is he oh he's still in
rainbow 16 how he's doing now and I think he's been in
diamond one the last I don't know the last one to two weeks
right now like the pro is in the trenches yeah it's been two
i won't be surprised if it's close to month number three i
just remember him i remember seeing that he's been in there
for a while
and it's not like it's not like he's and he's dueling too
he's like given up like to the point where he's now dueling
because and at first he was like solo is only i'm gonna get
to the highest rank in each of these games Solo only.
And then even he was like, I can't.
I can't.
I got it.
I need someone.
I need a duo.
Now it's like duo.
Yeah.
Now it's like solo or duo.
Oh my God.
He was even.
Right.
I was two, two today.
Oh my God.
He's still diamond one.
This poor man.
Someone fucking free this man.
It was supposed to be like a speed run but I don't think
it's a speed run no more Okay, I'll show you guys this
record is actually I feel so bad like I think he he did not
think this is how it's gonna go He really did not think so
this is record by the way This is current This poor man I
don't think he realized this was going to take him Almost
three months So he's like Timmy is racing in top rank in
seven games Two out of seven completed Apex 33 hours 33
hours CS2 140 hours And now you're wondering where is he
currently at What is he currently at Right now So you're
like Alright so he stopped at 100 440 hours in CS2.
Now where is he?
What is he currently at at Rainbow Six Siege?
This is his current hours in Rainbow Six Siege, by the way.
He has invested
400 plus hours on Rainbow Six Siege alone.
And he's only in Diamond, well, not only, but he's still in
Diamond 1.
And he's trying to get Champ 1, by the way.
He's still having, he's not like his next rank up.
His, his, ends in the next rank up.
He still needs to get Champ 5, Champ 4, Champ 3, Champ 2,
and then Champ 1.
Is that 22 days?
If you look at his VOD history, you can see that he was,
he's still, he's been streaming Rainbow Six Siege at least
two months.
He has played, that's three and a half months of working
full time.
No, it's more than a month, it's two plus months.
I think he's almost at the three month, he's almost at the
three months, right?
right now.
I feel I would be like, wait, he's still at Rainbow Six
Siege?
I feel so bad for him.
He's like actually stuck in purgatory.
He's stuck in Rainbow Six Siege purgatory at the moment.
Never give up.
No,
Next one is...
Next one is Fortnite.
He should put Rainbow...
I'm not gonna lie.
He should really put Rainbow Six Siege, like at the end.
Everything else seems so much easier in comparison.
For Gatoran, how you straight up in hell?
Oh, imagine he hits with Season Rank Reset.
Oh, Overwatch recently introduced a Season Rank Reset to
last...
For this season.
All right, I'm still trying to figure out what I want to do
tomorrow.
I don't know.
I mean the easiest thing is just play your rivals rank But I
don't really want to play I not I don't know like okay I
love I know I said it before I said it on Twitch stream for
those who don't watch me on Twitch But I love rivals.
I love rivals.
I can literally I haven't actually haven't played rivals the
last since I came Back from Bahamas.
It's like the since the tournament Moments because I really
am not huge huge fan of how toxic the community has gotten
in general and it's like i can't just turn off i feel i
can't just turn on voice chat too because or text actually
sometimes you know sometimes people aren't yelling at each
other you know so it's like i feel like if they come meet
with the the player base if the player base wasn't so toxic
or like it's just pain just pain honestly yeah It's gotten
really, really bad.
I think it's gotten to the point of...
League level bad.
But there's voice chat available.
Yeah, to the point where even, like, content creators and
pro play...
Like, a lot of pro players don't get punished for being,
like, super toxic or, like, throwing...
Because, like, some pro players get away with throwing
games.
Or, like, being, like, incredibly toxic.
And not, like, he, he, ha, ha, toxic.
But more so, like, I'm gonna try and make you...
cry in the middle of the game type toxic and um and it's
like gone to that point because like pro players don't even
get punished for it and similar with content creators um so
it's like it's it's been like really hard to play rank in
general just because it's like um you know I'm more of a
casual player I don't grind the game every day I play it
more so like as my free time for fun I play for fun off
stream but I've had so many instances where people were just
really really Not specifically, sometimes not even directed
at me, but it was just like, you know, the vibes were just
off, you know?
Like, it was just, like, bad vibes.
Overall.
It was just overall not a very fun experience to play
through.
And, um, and it's just like, I feel like it got worse.
It has gotten considerably a lot worse in general, uh, the
last few seasons to a point where, like, even I was just
like, yeah, I don't really want to play rank right now.
to play it yeah yeah i'm just like i don't really want to
play rink i don't want to get yelled at today i'm not going
to play rink today yeah it's just like i could i you know
i've been playing competitive games for a long time now like
since overwatch um but like i felt like it's got really
really bad um it got really really bad recently
will you play Overwatch again?
I want to play Overwatch again I just haven't had the time
to um because I want to like because I know a lot of
characters are a lot of characters I normally don't play as
meta now I don't want to I know there is a rank reset too so
like I do want to go back to Overwatch and try Playing a bit
more
I still don't know what to play Tomorrow Let me look at my
wish list What do I want to do?
I just don't really want to play it tomorrow I don't really
want to play Overwatch Tomorrow But um But um
What do I want to play But I
Don't want I want to do a one-off tomorrow.
I don't want to do like a series.
I want to do a one-off Because we're doing because I'm doing
it one.
I know we said double seven, but I want to like Finish armor
quarry first because I think I I think I fucked up by
starting a lot of game series Oh, we could try insane
aquarium deluxe.
That was a game that I have saved in here on my wish list
Oh, wait, we could do...
I don't know if I want to do a rage game, honestly.
I don't really want to do a rage game.
There is a rage game that I have on my wish list, but I
don't know about...
I don't know.
Maybe no rage.
Maybe me want to chill.
I'm like, do I want to play my little puppy and fucking
clown?
No, I'm already, I already cried today.
Like I said, I had a really bad day today.
A really, really bad day.
The
library game.
What's that?
Bum, bum.
It's just one of those days, you know?
You know what I wish?
I wish, like, you know, there's a lot of games that have
Twitch integration.
I wish there were more games.
I wish, I wish, like, YouTube's API was not so ass that we
could do, like, YouTube integration for fun things.
I love, like, Twitch integration with games.
I don't stream on Twitch enough to do it.
You want something sort of mindless?
Bills must be paid.
It's pretty fun for a one-off.
Affiliate.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Must be paid.
Oh, I saw that.
One of my friends recommended me this game.
It's like an idle game.
I heard it was really, really fun.
Hmm.
Game about digging holes.
Oh, I have that on my wish list, too.
Record play.
What's this game called?
Okay, let me check my Discord.
I have it on my Discord.
Let's see, games.
Some, do I still save it?
Oh, I didn't save it.
God damn it.
It was, oh wait, it's because I have it on.
No, I should know.
It might not be up.
Never mind.
Ignore what I said.
Hmm.
Yoki?
What if I did play Rivals?
No, I feel like people are gonna be so mean.
I feel like people are gonna be so mean.
I was like, what if I just, what if I do play Rivals?
I was like, no, I can feel it.
I could play Monster Ranch.
I've been wanting to play Monster Ranch for a while.
Yeah.
I could play Fortnite.
I want to get on Fortnite when they release the Sonic
collab.
Wait, what's in the Fortnite shop right now?
Alright, what's in today's current items in Fortnite?
The last time I was on it, I bought the Digital Circus
Cosmere.
That's the last time.
Oh, the office is back.
Oh, I heard, yeah, I forgot.
They released the...
What is it called?
Ark Knights collab?
yeah i heard nintendo nintendo respond finally responded
back
let's see there's arc knights there's furries
there's masters of the universe there's he man okay tyler
the creator ariana grande but when is when are the video
game collabs coming
When are the video game...
Does anyone know when the video game collabs are coming?
When is Sonic?
Oh my god.
Sonic on the Battle Pass.
Oh, is Sonic on the Battle Pass?
Okay.
The 20th?
Alright.
I can get it.
I can get it before I go.
I still don't know.
I'm just thinking maybe Overwatch, but I really...
I don't know.
I feel like I need to, like, remember how to play Overwatch
before I stream Overwatch.
I feel like I need to remember how to play Overwatch to
stream it.
That's the thing.
I always feel like I have to remember it.
I need to, like, not be told.
Total ass on stream.
I can be ass, but I don't want to be that ass.
That's a great thing about Overwatch.
If I'm ass, I'll just play Anna.
Anna never changes.
Good old Anna.
Always the same.
You shoot at a person, they live.
It's like riding a bike My classic fallback pick Exactly
No matter what Anna will still be there for me No matter
what happens The good old reliable
I've been stuck on my third task For Two and a half hours
now I've been stuck on this fucking third task I'm trying my
best I'm trying to figure out
The answer DM Well it's actually the Schedule The schedule
task
You want something Oh wait, oh I already read that I don't
know why I thought it was a new super chat
What is this The little sim world No.
Alright.
I don't want to do a simulator game.
I'm an evil horse dealer simulator.
Maybe I do want to do a simulator game.
With 22 reviews.
Trade horses for new life feed and regenerations of elite
stallions.
Race horses.
Draft mouse.
War horses and more.
If only I could do choice or voicer on YouTube.
If only.
Oh, I saw Agent 64 on Steam.
Yeah, I'm planning on streaming Choicer Voicer, but it'll be
on Wednesday.
Why am I doing that on Wednesday?
It's hard.
Because I want to do something that we both want to enjoy,
you know?
Or just play something we both enjoy.
Horsy game.
quell thank you thank you well we're never gonna we're never
gonna beat the peak of what's it yeah yeah wait i said
actually said that to i said that to ben for those who don't
know who ben is it's mr cow um for those who don't know who
mr cow is so when we replay with sure for it's always like
me uh me ben gully and then recently uh rain and Mew are the
two new additions.
So, it's mostly me off stream, but the rare time I did
stream was for the Isle.
Anyway, so Ben was watching me play horse magnifier game,
and he was like, what the fuck are you?
He actually was, he was watching me play the horse magnifier
game.
And he was like, what the fuck is this?
And he was like, wait, have you ever played the horsey game?
Those who don't know what the horsey game is, it's where you
also breed horses to make the most optimal horse.
And if you're still confused as to what the fuck is going on
in the horsey game.
So I made the perfect horse.
His name is, yeah!
And this is when I first made it.
Yeah, this is all on Twitch, by the way.
This is all on Twitch.
I don't remember what I was doing.
I just, I don't remember why we were streaming this on
Twitch.
Like,
wasn't even, it was, like, it was, like, it was, his name
was, yeah!
So, I did not think he would move when I first made him.
And, so, this was, yeah!
And then, I entered him in the race.
I...
So many of Bob Nations.
Yeah, was the perfect horse I've ever made in that game.
We started with yeah, we end with yeah.
It was technically alive.
Yeah.
Technically a horse.
Ball X Pit.
Oh yeah, Matara told me to play this.
too.
Hey, I entered it in a horse race, so technically it's a
horse.
If I'm able to enter in a horse race, it's technically a
It checks all the boxes.
I wish I don't know if I want to play ball pit, though.
I thought about it, but I was like, I don't really...
I don't really want to play that type of game.
Yeah, it was allowed to enter the horse race, so it's a
horse.
Barbie detectives.
game.
Let's see.
Bum.
Wish I could.
It seems fun.
I wish I could play Adora the Explorer game, but I didn't
have to like program a PC to allow me.
I think that's one of the things I would love to play.
I could just play Adora the Explorer game.
Dada, Dada, Dada, Dada, Dada.
D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-Emm-DOM-DOM-DOM-DOM
If only...
That'll be a dream come true.
Is there one on Steam?
It's not the same.
If there is, it's not the same.
There isn't.
Bada-Bada-Bada-Bada.
It's so hard to pick a game.
It's so difficult.
Let's see.
There's one where I open a casino.
I think we have enough gambling for the week.
Might be enough gambling for the week, guys.
Yeah, but Dino Blade isn't really a one-off.
It's a long-ass game.
I don't really want to do, like, a heavy...
A heavy...
Uh...
Let's see.
A heavy, like, multiplayer game.
Or, like, a heavy rage game.
Not multiplayer, it's not heavy.
series game or a or rage game right now so I play a game why
is it so hard to find a game
it's all I want a game but also I have but also here are my
list of criteria that must tick it's so simple it's all I
want I want something so simple but it It can't be a
multiplayer game.
It can't be a series.
It has to be a one-off.
Um, not too...
I don't really want to do gambling right now.
And, uh, I don't want to do, like, a...
Like, I don't want to play Rank.
And I also, uh, don't really want to play a rage game.
And, oh my god, it's so simple.
I just won a game.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh my god.
There's one, like...
Something, I just want one, just like, any game.
You know?
I'm not even that picky, guys.
God.
Wonderful.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What's this?
Time to go back to DD Dinosaur with Dungeons.
How about these?
You're reliable.
Thank you for the super chat, Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you.
Oh my god, workout dude is gone.
Where did he go?
He stopped working out.
What about your gains, bro?
What about your gains?
If anyone else wants to join this session.
Bro!
you're not care about the your gains that's quitter talk
right there but he worked up so hard he ascended bro
slacking what's this oh this is a co-op game god damn it i
wish there was so many friend slop because They keep
announcing friend slops.
That's quitter talk.
There's no such thing as too much gains.
I also have a game where I don't have to read too much.
I don't really want to do narration right now.
You can play Class of...
Oh, okay.
That's...
Speak up the double.
I don't want to narrate too much.
NSD, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I could woo some women.
Let's see.
There it is.
Alright, let's see.
Choose your own...
Let's choose your own adventure games.
I could watch a game.
Oh my god.
I could play mixtape.
The perfect game.
Doki, I don't know if you've seen this, but one of my
favorite games is horse riding.
classic on Steam.
I feel like I've seen that game before.
I think it was Super Chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I could play a game, guys.
I could play mixtape.
I could watch a game.
The perfect game.
Oh my god, I was scared of shit out of me.
The trailer played for uh...
for a game.
Let's see.
What can we do?
You know what?
I know what to do.
What are the streamers doing these days?
What are...
You can play a rat claw and you totally won't get stuck into
that for eight hours.
We're not doing that again.
I've had my fix of rat clawing.
That's a one Done deal.
Excel.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
That's okay, guys.
We do not have to play Ratcoin again.
Featured, free to play.
I don't know where to pop.
A new one's trending.
Evil school.
What's this?
This game is an FMV about anti-bullying.
Oh, it called Evil School.
Now you turn to place some evil.
The moment of slay and judgment has arrived.
I don't know.
Sounds evil.
Sounds pretty evil.
Oh, there is forbidden solitaire.
I played...
Uh...
I guess forbidden solitaire.
I do have that on my wish list, but I see a lot of reading.
God, I'm not picky at all.
Why is this so hard?
why is it so difficult to pick one game I don't ask for much
oh my god just
do karaoke I
don't know bro I'm actually gonna put Marvel Rivals in Doki,
all that, and you're just gonna put Marvel Rival.
Imagine.
And after all, after spending, how, Doki, no.
After spending an hour trying to sign, it's like, Marvel
Rebels.
I'm joking, I'm joking.
I'm actually, I'm still looking through.
I'm still looking through.
What if I just put Marvel Rivals?
I'm actually, I'm still looking through the options.
Okay, there is this game, but then I was like, I, AI to you
with you till the end.
But it's like, by the reviews of it looks, I don't know.
So it's like, what's the word?
It's like basically trying to escape your evil AI girlfriend
or something.
Do you think that's interesting to play?
I could try that game.
This one.
It's like those like chat boxes, you know?
Yeah, it's like me side, but like you can talk to them.
I'm joking.
I'm joking unless.
Jokeybird.
Space thing.
If it's Super Chat, they could think.
I mean, the reviews aren't bad.
I'll try.
Maybe I'll try this.
I'll put that on my schedule.
We'll do that.
We'll do that five.
Uh...
We'll do that, then.
Alright.
Schedule complete.
Uh...
I'll finalize the schedule.
No, I mean it's finalized technically.
So, I'll just...
It's my Photoshop.
I'm gonna put this on Photoshop.
This chat is becoming...
You can't do React Andy on YouTube, though.
You have to React Andy on Twitch.
Or they'll get you.
They got him.
What do you mean they just got him?
They're gonna get me, guys.
If I do that on YouTube.
So they released more Spongebob merch.
Look at this.
I love the tweet.
That's a good tweet.
I actually want this.
I want this cat.
Look at this cat.
I want this merch.
Look at that.
If he kept going on his games.
It could have looked like a peak.
This is what peak human...
Well, not human.
This is what peak specimen looks like, guys.
That could have been you if you kept on working on your
gains.
That could have been you.
This is where the workout guy went.
He got turned into a blind box.
All right, let's see you.
Let me make my schedule.
All right.
What the fuck?
Why is there a guy up above me?
Where did this guy come from?
I just noticed a random dude above me.
on sunday what the no i didn't i did not stream on sunday
climb the pomdoro tree what is he doing up here
all right schedule time
okay monday
good tuesday stream wednesday stream um Okay, Wednesday two
streams on good old Wednesday.
Okay, multiple streams.
Thursday, Friday.
Friday.
Oh, nope.
Get rid of multi.
Don't stream.
Don't stream on Saturday.
No stream on Saturday, guys.
I repeat, no stream on Saturday.
Oh, is it no stream on Sunday?
No, no stream on Saturday.
all right okay but what if i don't think i will have access
to anything that will let me stream on saturday i refuse to
bring my laptop
every time i bring my laptop i don't stream today you can't
you can't fool me again i finally learned but like what but
What if you what if that's the day you're travel and then
you're actually gonna stream?
Oh, yeah, funny story.
Oh my god, I forgot to tell you guys this funny story.
Did I tell you okay?
Wait, actually did I tell you this story yet?
Oh wait, I didn't so I actually had to lend my suitcase that
I bought That I bought just for the vacation to the friend
to the the the to my friend whose place I was crashing in
for the sponsor slash tournaments because they had to uh
they didn't want to buy a new suitcase as well because they
also broke their suitcase and they're like oh can I borrow
your suitcase because I don't really want to spend money to
buy a new suitcase for their trip later on so I was like
yeah it's cool because like they only have like carry-ons so
they didn't have like a big suitcase because they have to um
so I was like no that's
because I didn't bring that much anyway.
So I was just like, oh my God, the guy got stabbed.
Where did he go?
The guy on the tree disappeared.
Anyway, so I swapped suitcases with them and came back with
a carry-on.
But the thing is, I forgot what the carry-on looked like.
When I...
So when I came back, you know, on my flight to get my
luggage, I forgot what it looked like.
I was like, is this my, no, is this my suitcase?
I was just like, waiting at the back and stern will be like,
oh, fuck.
Like, which one is my suitcase?
Fuck.
So I didn't do it was like no really and he tags on it I
just knew it was a carry-on So I was just like okay, it's a
small suitcase It's very small But that I in my head I still
thought it was bigger than what it actually Because I
apparently I looked at it I saw that suitcase five times in
rotation But it never clicked in my head that that one was
mine Because I was like that's too small Like I was like,
all right, I know it was like brownish.
Like, I was just, I, okay, it was a brownish color, and it
was small, but it wasn't that small.
Like, so, so I was just like, I was like, is that, no, that
can't be my, that's too small.
yeah so and I was just like maybe that was my suit at one
point I was just like you know I'm just gonna check every
tiny suitcase until I see the luggage tag that said
dokeybird not obviously not gonna be dokeybird but like my
name on it so I just started checking every small suitcase
that was like brownish tanish because I was like I know it
was brown But I was like, was it brown?
But I was doubting myself.
I was just like, oh, but was it brown?
Like, maybe it was like tan.
Or like black.
I don't remember.
I was just like, fuck, I should have remembered what the
suitcase looked like.
I should.
When I made the swap, I should have remembered what it
actually looked like.
So I started checking all the tags.
Like, oh, no, not mine.
Oh, oh, there it is.
I was like, oh, it was that.
Oh, I thought it was a little bigger.
That's something you don't want to hear.
I just like, oh, man.
I thought it was a little bigger.
You'll remember it being this small.
Things you don't want to hear.
oh hey silent i mean you've been working very hard behind
the scenes i do not think we ever had things this busy
before on the business i don't remember what i said that was
this reply what did i say silent i don't remember i said so
many things
i don't remember what it was directed to is it is it this
one where I wrote stop crying Doki and it's still not
checked off yet is that what it's addressed to
oh I think silent left he just wanted to do a mental health
check he's like gotta make sure she's not crying on stream
oh She's okay.
All right.
I'll leave now.
I'm doing a daily mental health check.
Wellness check on me.
Yeah.
What is this?
Oh, maybe not that one.
Guys, what was he talking about when he said that, guys?
What was he vague tweeting about?
Where's my context clues?
What is he replying to?
I need my context clues
Don't worry about it.
Don't make me message and be like what are you saying?
Oh no stream on Saturday?
Yeah, we'll never know It was vague tweeting.
I need to know.
Okay, pal world
Oh, yeah.
I mean, I have been.
And I'm going to do next year.
I'm going to do less convention.
I know I keep saying that every year.
But next year, I'm going to do less conventions.
Because I want to focus more on personal stuff.
I focus, want to focus.
Yeah, I said that last time.
For real.
I want to focus more on personal projects this year.
Or next year.
Okay, the choicer voicer.
Yeah.
Yeah, that stuff was happening.
But I really do want to focus more on more personal projects
for this year, for next year.
Like, I know it's like means like less, uh, I guess like
networking.
I don't know, not networking.
but less event not but i want to do like events but on my
personal chat but not like what's the word like just less
appearances i guess for next year because like i said i just
want to do more more stuff like on online next year more
expo yeah less exposure i guess
i don't want to work i want to focus on something different
Oops.
Okay, I'm making my schedule right now.
What the fuck is the font so big?
I have 4.62.
4.62.
There we go.
That's my font size.
Alright, what am I doing on...
Okay, armor core.
More armor core.
Okay, armored core.
My eyes feel so heavy.
I think it's because, like, I cried earlier this morning.
Like I said, like, I'm not going to, like, jerk out or
anything.
I did have, like, a little breakdown this morning.
Like I said, I had a really rough day.
So I think that's why my eyes are tired.
I really needed a stream, though.
I always feel better whenever I stream.
If I had a bad day, is it, like, my serotonin?
Or I continue the cycle.
I continue the cycle.
If I'm going to have a bad day, someone else is also going
to have a bad day.
Wait, no.
Is it Capcom HQ or Capcom Studio?
Valve Studio, blah, blah, blah.
I know I said it before, but I don't remember if that's the
term.
It's Studio, right?
Like, their offices?
Their Capcom offices?
Offices?
I don't know what even is called.
Check my car.
Office is safe in general.
But it's like, Studio, Capcom, Office.
Capcom Studio.
Capcom.
Well, they were just like, do you want to come to Capcom?
Do you want to come to...
Did I say Capcom Office?
No, man.
Let me check my Discord messages.
Very professional.
My professional communication.
My Discord messages.
Oh, it was Office.
Capcom Office.
I feel like studio would sound nicer, though.
Capcom, USA.
Why should I say USA, office, studio.
Capcom house.
HQ sounds cooler, though.
Capcom, USA, HQ.
Crib.
Capcom's crib.
I'll do studio
Quick chopper ride At Capcom HQ Alright special event at
Capcom USA HQ Headquarters Headquarters Ah so many choices
There's so many choices guys Which was the right choice
So the HQ office crib I'm going to say that I'm going to
write all of it HQ, office, crib and then studio.
I'll just put it all there.
TTV at Facebook.
Bro, I do not trust helicopters anymore after all the
helicopter accidents.
I I don't know.
I never been on a helicopter.
I don't think I'll ever be on a helicopter.
I don't think I'm...
That ain't happening anytime at all.
It's 16 to...
Oh my god, the last time I made an actual schedule was in
July.
August 22nd.
Alright, um, well, I almost finished everything.
I'm gonna check that off the list.
How I'm gonna stream for?
Oh my gosh, three hours.
Alright.
I did it.
I made my schedule.
Now I just got answer DMs, answer DMs, answer DMs, and
answer DMs.
Just three hours later.
Guys, I did my 13 task.
Now I can take a 10-hour break.
I've not been following my, what is this called?
The Pomodoro, whatever the fuck it is.
And stop crying at some point one day.
Today's not that day.
Oh!
I reset the clock.
last oh we're resetting yay got my five minute break let's
go i've been definitely following that religiously yippee
time to scroll twitter
yay definitely i've been following that
for real for real
All right.
All right, I'll start one more DM and I'll actually...
I'll work more off stream, I promise, guys.
And then my mind...
She did not work more off.
Then my mind would be like, don't lie.
It's good to see.
He's not watching right now.
He did his mental...
He did his wellness check and then left.
So he'll never know.
Yeah.
I'll forward this over to...
I'll never know.
I already did his wellness check, so I'm free.
Doug, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Have the call here for me, but I hope you have a better day
tomorrow.
Oh, we're able to help out even a little.
Of course, you guys helped out a lot.
I was feeling really...
Um, I'm really, I guess, like, I should I say depressed?
I did.
I was feeling really depressed and sad today.
But you guys helped out a lot.
You guys always cheer me up.
I knew I had to stream.
I was debating a little bit.
But I was like, I know, like, if I stream, I'd feel a lot
better in general.
So I'm really happy to stream for you guys.
Because you guys help improve my mood.
And I hope I help improve your mood, too.
I just love hanging out with you guys.
Um, this one.
all right i did it i have to go to dm m oh all right i'm
gonna call it here everybody thank you so much for hanging
out with me today and it was like a sort of like a surprise
stream um uh but i hope you guys enjoyed just hanging out
relaxing being a little comfy helping me vacuum my sand did
you guys did you guys enjoyed my sad guys do you have fun
we've all the vacuuming around on the beach that's right
that's what was going on you're all vacuuming sand yeah
we're still at it don't worry one day we're gonna finish
vacuuming all the sand.
What is this?
It's called On Together Virtual Co-Worky.
I want to try it.
I just thought it was cute on the screen.
I just thought it was cute.
That's really it.
That's why it's on the screen.
I thought it was a little silly.
Where will the sand go?
We'll never know.
Where...
hey guys i'm gonna head off now thank you for hanging out
with me thank you for being productive with me everybody i
hope you guys also have been productive in whatever you were
doing um next seat they give us super chat thank you thank
you thank you for vacuuming sand with me as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around get that
blood flowing deserve it i'll show you guys a little preview
of the schedule since i know so you guys were like but what
what was in the schedule here's a little preview of it um
i'll give you guys because i'll be posting this later today
i almost done i'm already uh there you go let me save it
real quick so i can show it to you guys on the on the stream
well work mode don't worry i am showing this right now all
right where's the here it is uh
all right so here you go uh this is basically the schedule
uh armor core tuesday tomorrow i to you wednesday members
pal world choicer voicer thursday armor core we're see we
can we're do a long-term armor course see how far we can get
we'll get the other ending uh friday special event at capcom
studio all right guys that's a preview for this week i'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye thanks for
hanging out with me i really appreciate thanks for working
with me too um trying to be productive and everything i said
i knew i wanted to stream because like i said um i won't be
streaming saturday so that would have been three rest days
but i'd rather just like get a stream out today and i was
really great today too so i knew like this would be a little
hope to.
Hey guys, bye everybody.
Bye-bye.